what with the inspiration for both of
you two to get involved in the
the industry while we would have a cat
what I was doing it 11:00 and I and I
realized that I was I had the bug early
not in with a camera and I wonder what I
was making little plays and my you know
my sitting room behind the bay window I
just think it's incredible now with the
iPhone and iPad everyone's got these
live access you saying that you can edit
and still all the sound I mean I have no
idea how to do that so for me the bug
was there but it didn't have the access
to the technology so yeah kids are so
multi-talented now as well now you've
got your own tubes well are they
interested in all this sort of stuff
yeah they are obviously I'm trying to
steer them away from the acting side of
things and towards plumbing and
accountancy but no I love filmmaking
because it's so inclusive and all the
different skills that are involved not
just messing about in pretty clothes but
actually the the skills involved the
digital effects and sound and costume
and I I am in all of the these guys
because they are actually making the
films whereas I'm just employed by
people who make films you've come such a
long way obviously over the years I mean
we've got you coming up in Doctor Who in
the 50th anniversary year how is that it
was great I am yeah I have to have now
since become a Doctor Who fan but when I
was there on set with the sonic I didn't
quite realize have held it in the or and
didn't really realize the the magnitude
of why I was on no it was great and
obviously it's an amazing program and
the guys here on it or as you saying all
these people the crew and their and and
Matt and Jennifer it's a great great
thing to be part of so yeah you didn't
take in at the time how important it was
the Ice Warriors are back first time
since the 17th no I came face to face
with this eyesore and everyone told me
mark who write the roads they told me
this is a really big event so I only
really realised them in hindsight but
and yeah we'll see hopefully
and Livia we've got loads of films a
plethora of them coming up from you over
the next year or two tell us a little
bit about some of them I'm actually most
excited about last days on Mars where I
got to be an astronaut and we were
running around the Red Desert in Jordan
in spacesuits but it's a really
phenomenal piece it's actually really
just about what happens to astronauts or
any human being when they're in a
confined space for too long some great
actors Liev Schreiber and Ramallah Gary
and yeah but that's the one I'm excited
about it's been pretty hot though in a
suit like that in the desert hot doesn't
actually begin to describe how miserable
it was but but you know one suffers for
one's heart
you